[Music]
all right as I announced yesterday I
have officially left New York state for
good uh not going back I'm now a
full-time resident in the Free State of
Florida something frankly I've wanted to
do for years and back in 2014 when I
first well floated the idea well John
Stewart on The Daily Show well he
Enlisted the likes of Nathan Lane and
the Jersey Boys I took it as a great
compliment and they actually wrote a
song for me begging me to stay take a
look Sean we know you're mad at us and
you have every right to be Occupy Wall
Street Governor Cuomo that weird smell
New York has made a lot of big mistakes
but we're going to change just please
stay stay stay we can't lose you stay yo
Sean man you can't leave we need you dog
man I will lose my accent if you stay
let's grab a beer and watch the game
how's that we'll make sex in the city
tours Sean in the city tours go if you
stay we'll cut off our hoodies we're in
love but we'll marry women instead we
was stop selling halal food we will sell
Apple pip that Keystone Pipeline will
run it through Central Park no
problem what's a hoodie without a hood
the city depends upon job creators like
you Sean so we're going to give you the
perks you deserve we'll name a street
after Reagan hell we'll name them all
after Reagan worried about your commute
home no problem this a train is now
running directly to Sea's
house take a out Please Stay Stay Stay
Stay
Stay Stay Mr hity
Stay what do we do if you g away who
would we tax till his money was gone who
would we impose socialism
upon
Mr
mray life and an stay in your first and
second homes don't disapp
Forever Mr hanity Mr
hanity to your infity keep your unique
friend and far Insanity safely away from
the rest of
humanity St
Mr whatever may do or say in the state
that fills you with hate that's the
state you
[Applause]
anyway
[Music]
Mr on second thought who gives a what
you
do I think that's the real sentiment I'm
sure they're all sad to that I finally
left anyway here with reaction the host
of a brand new show we get to announce
it right here Fox News Saturday Night
with Jimmy b and a premier is January
13th we're proud of you you're staying
I'm I left yeah by the way Hannity you
find out I get a show you move out of
the state the next day what's up with
that man what's up with it was it was
just bad timing I had no idea but I'm
proud of you we're happy for you you
deserve it uh you're an amazing talent
um I try to do a little of what you do
you've seen me do it I'm not I'll never
be as good but I admire what you do well
listen I love you and you know this
wouldn't be possible without you uh
everyone's been asking me what your
Cut's going to be they're like how much
does Shawn want is this like The
Sopranos do does Shawn get to wet his
beak like on The Sopranos but anyway two
concerns here Hannity okay you've been
in Florida 48 hours and you haven't cut
the sleeves off your jacket yet are you
sure you're a real Floridian and how
come there's no plastic on that chair
you haven't even plastic to
chair I said well I brought my old chair
with me and one thing I took from New
York uh but by the way I mean I actually
I think John Stewart I thought he was
really funny even when he did make fun
of me I was blown away by that
production it might have kept me in New
York longer uh than I wanted to stay I
have two points one I legitimately did
think that was a good video because the
steuart Daily Show had a lot of funny
elements to it the mod Daily Show as you
know tickets are $10 to get in and a 100
to get out it's not the best show okay
but Sean you should be concerned that
the Daily Show made a bigger effort to
keep you than we did okay we love you
but we did not make that video I mean I
would have made that video for your
staff because I love your staff and I
love their families but I I feel like we
owe you that video
Sean uh look fox has been great I have
no complaints I if you would have bet in
1996 I'd be you know one of the last
people standing that was a Bad Bet
congratulations Saturday night 10:00
we'll be watching Jimmy FAA thank you
sir hey Sean Hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to Fox News YouTube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere
else